hey guys how's it going happy tech
Tuesday I am currently well I'm
currently filming this video right now
but this week I'm shooting something
really fun and really secret I can't
wait for you guys to see it so I'm just
doing a very simple tech Tuesday because
a lot of you guys have been questioning
what I've been doing with a GoPro lately
and I've been filming a lot in the car
and that was actually inspired by mr.
nadeshot he got a GoPro and he's been
like putting it in his new G wagon and
filming and I was like that's a good
idea so I started doing that so I'll
show you what I'm using to film in my
car but I also recently shot a really
fun video that will be out in a few
weeks and we decided to rig the kitchen
so that I can film with a GoPro at night
clipped it up here to this lamp and then
we used one of these multi chargers
connected to the GoPro to sort of be an
external power source because usually
GoPros do tend to lose battery pretty
quickly so you do want to have sort of
an extra backup in addition to that I
also was using another extra battery
backup which you can charge two
batteries at the same time and then plug
that in via USB to the wall or to your
computer so you're able to sort of
always have a battery backup no matter
where you are another little clip that I
have been using a lot is this I don't
even know actually what this clip is
supposed to be used for but I clip this
to pretty much everything and this is
what I clip to my car when I'm filming
play just give another shot here so you
can see what I'm gonna be talking about
one of my favorite things about using a
GoPro is you're able to use your
smartphone to see what is actually being
filmed from your GoPro so if I have this
pink clip from the ceiling like I'm
gonna do now very very carefully
you guys can see exactly what is going
on from that view right here on the
phone so I've got a lot of cameras going
on we got one here where that one never
go in here filming this so now let me
take you into the car so I can show you
where I mount my GoPro when I'm driving
oh really dark but that's okay so what
I've been using a lot is this clamp and
this is awesome because you can pretty
much clamp this on to anything I've
clamped this on to skateboards I've
clamped this on to as you saw my lamb
pretty much anything and it's really
really strong and it just uses one of
those little I'm really sure what the
technical term is but you can just slide
that right out and put this mount onto
something else
but what we're gonna do now unscrew this
and put on one of my favorite little
clamps dunno what it is I'll look it up
I'll put it in the description see you
guys oh no what awesome Oh God
you might also notice that I'm using
this little frame here also don't know
what that's called but I love it because
it's not one of the full housing so when
I'm just kind of out vlogging and around
and trying to get this screw in here it
gives you access to pretty much
everything on your GoPro I also have a
little lens cover on here because this
GoPro really doesn't ever go inside of
any of the waterproof housing so it's
pretty much an on-the-go camera this is
where I put it
I'll just stick it right there inside
the air buds and when I film I don't
have the key in my car right now so I
can actually start it but when I do
start it this navigation oh it works
without starting the car that pops up
and I can just click this right here to
get all the outside shots but I want to
get so to review the things that I
talked about today is this little clip
which I don't know the name of this
outside frame clip which I all said hold
your dreams of this clamp those cute
little lens cap and the GoPro itself
this is the hero4 black let's go back
inside
there's a link in the description to my
blog that I'll write up everything that
I talked about today that I don't know
the name of sometime you
your name what works works okay let's
get out of here thank you guys so much
for watching this tech Tuesday I hope
you guys have a great week I will see
you next Tuesday let me know what you
guys would like to see possibly in the
next episode and yes I probably will
talk more about iPhones or iPads or
Apple things cuz yep it's my favorite
I'll see you guys soon don't forget to
like this video if you liked it and
subscribe if you know how its really
difficult you just click the button see
you later yeah that's good that's nice
so already how I think eleven twelve
Oh